bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
taekwondo les championnats
départementaux étaient organisées ce
week-end au gymnase paul bailly de
trappes pour la deuxième année
consécutive 400 combattants se sont
affrontés lors de la compétition les
détails dans ce magazine
aviron nous recevrons dans cette
émission thomas baroque licencié au
cercle nautique de versailles deux fois
médaillé aux championnats du monde pour
reviendront sur sa carrière et ses
objectifs olympique cet été à rio
football américain cette année la
section des moins de 16 ans des
pampilles est en cours l'équipe de
football américain de saint quentin en
yvelines a été relancée les apprentis
temples y ont joué ce week-end leur
premier match de la saison reportage à
suivre
et puis l'essentiel de l'actualité
sportive du département nous parlerons
notamment de l'élimination du fc mantois
78 en 16e de finale de la coupe de
france contre nantes
les championnats départementaux de
taekwondo était organisée ce week-end au
gymnase paul mallet de trappes pour la
deuxième année consécutive
au total 400 combattants se sont
affrontés pour se qualifier pour les
championnats de france
les images sont signés à william l des
coups impressionnants et déplacement
ultra rapide le spectacle était au
rendez-vous ce week-end au gymnase paul
mallet des trappes et championnats
départementaux de taekwondo est organisé
pendant deux jours dans la structure une
centaine de combat de neuf minutes
étaient au programme un sac poubelle et
sélective pour la coupe de france donc
il se déroulera au mois de mai au niveau
national et
dans chacune des régions de france cette
compétition a lieu entre novembre et
février
au total 400 combattants âgés de 8 à 14
ans se sont affrontés sur les deux jours
de compétition
pour certains c'est vraiment une
animation sportive
on sent sous la halle pour eux l'enjeu
c'est pas spécialement de se qualifier
mais c'est déjà d'être présent c'est
déjà de participer et c'est déjà
d'essayer de faire la meilleure
prestation devant un papa maman quand on
est atteint la deuxième catégorie des
participants c'est vraiment jouer la
qualification parce que cette
compétition s'inscrit dans un programme
de formation et un calendrier sportif
qui doit les amener sur les plus hautes
marches nationales
le taekwondo compte quinze mille six
cents licenciés en ile de france
répartis dans une centaine de clubs on
ouvre à présent une page aviron avant de
recevoir sur ce plateau thomas bach ou
que deux fois médaillé aux championnats
du monde le 7 8 sport vous propose un
coup de projecteur
c'est sans doute la nouvelle pépite du
cercle nautique de versailles à 16 ans
arthur le maire originaire de plaisir
vise une place en équipe de france
d'aviron
le prodige a déjà remporté un titre de
champion de france en 2013 et les
régates de versailles au maroc fini à
pour le montage l'équipe de france
d'aviron pourrait l'accueillir dans les
prochaines années à saison arthur le
maire licencié au cercle nautique de
versets est considéré comme un grand
espoir de la discipline
le rameur originaire de plaisir s'est
lancé dans ce sport en 2012 j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir un père qui est là prat
qui a pratiqué ce sport quand il était
plus jeune et ne trouvons pas de sport
qui mal et il m'a redirigé vers ce sport
là qui m'a beaucoup plu depuis quatre
ans arthur le maire collectionne les
titres et marche sur les traces des
grands noms du club comme thomas barrau
que médaillé de bronze aux championnats
du monde en 2015 en 2013 j'ai été
champion de france en quatre de couple
barré avec un équipage du coup de quatre
rameurs ans
avec deux avions chacun en 2014
on a été champion des régates de
versailles nokia régate qui se déroule
ici dans nos jardins de versailles pour
intégrer la sélection tricolore arthur
s'entraîne cinq fois par semaine avec 10
heures de navigation des séances de
renforcement musculaire sont également
au programme pour le jeune prodige dans
nos centres musculation retravaille à
peu près tout le corps on a des séances
assez particulière donc des séances pour
travailler l'endurance au travail de
fond donc avec beaucoup de répétitions
et des séances pour la prise de masse
donc peu de répétitions mais des gros
groupes fois ça devient une sorte de
passion on y va parce que c'est devenu
une habitude mais aussi parce qu'on sait
que à la clé il ya peut-être un résultat
des cessions qui pourraient porter leurs
fruits le 30 janvier prochain pendant
les championnats de france d'aviron une
compétition indoor programmé au stade
coubertin à paris
on reste dans l'aviron après ce zoom sur
arthur le maire nous recevons donc sur
ce plateau thomas baruch deux fois
médaillé aux championnats du monde trois
médailles d'argent aux championnats
d'europe est deux fois deux fois
champion de france et vous avez
participé aux jeux olympiques de 2012 à
londres
je me trompe pas dans votre palmarès
c'est bon c'est bon il a joué au hockey
parfait
nous sommes également sur ce plateau à
denis langue d'art le président du
cercle nautique de versailles bonsoir
alors avant de parler de vous thomas un
petit réaction par rapport à arthur
c'est une pépite également de ces sacrés
natif de versailles
c'est un jeune prometteur pour atteindre
les objectifs qu'il s'est fixés alors
qu'il continue à bien travailler à être
patients parce que le haut niveau ça
vient avec le temps c'est un travail de
long terme
c'est un jeune qui progresse vous voyez
c'est un jeune qui progresse depuis
quelques années je vois s'entraîner
alors pas tous les jours parce que je
suis pas mal absents ces temps ci mais
chaque fois que je viens au club et
qu'on se croise effectivement je le vois
travailler correctement qu'il est serein
sur le bon chemin vous êtes déjà ramené
avec lui pas encore si j'ai ramé est
cuit
une ou deux fois je crois cette année et
c'est une pépite également pour le sac
mythique de versailles serait ce que je
disais alors nous on a besoin d'avoir un
nombre de rameurs importance qui compte
cette durée 1 dans le sport c'est la
question c'est effectivement on a du
potentiel
le potentiel c'est une question
importante mais on est un sport qui
demande beaucoup de travail donc pour
l'instant il ya du potentiel
il ya du travail et on souhaite qu'ils
puissent travailler dans le temps
évidemment avec en associant dans un
sport qui est bénévole qui est amateur
en associant les études et le sport ce
qui est pas facile toujours
ils représentent l'avenir et que
représente un des éléments possibles
pour l'avenir
alors nous allons revenir sur votre
actualité à thomas on y est on va
surtout rentrer dans le vif du sujet
tout de suite avec les jeux olympiques
2016 qui sont programmés à rio où l été
prochain
c'est un objectif c'est l'objectif de la
saison vraiment et c'est vous allez
préparer le rendez-vous petit à petit
c'est clairement l'objectif de la saison
il ya des étapes intermédiaires
justement pour y parvenir mais c'est
même au delà de juste le logis de la
saison c'était l'objectif de ma carrière
au moment où je me suis lancé dans
l'aventuré du haut niveau en 2009 cette
voie là j'ai fait je les jeux olympiques
de londres en 2012 mais c'était presque
inespéré j'y croyais pas vraiment au
début puis bon j'ai réussi à y aller
donc forcément une fois qu'on y est on
ne va pas faire de la figuration mais
clairement l'objectif c'était 2016 parce
que je savais qu'il fallait du temps
pour être prêt faute à son meilleur
niveau et je pense que je ne suis pas
très loin même si on essaie toujours
d'aller gratter dans les petites marges
de progression qui reste un peu partout
et comment prépare-t-on justement un
rendez-vous comme comme celui-là on mise
tout sur ce rendez vous où est-ce qu'il
faut passer par rapport à toutes ces
petites étapes intermédiaires
alors en fait l'entraîneur une saison
olympique n'est pas différent d'une
saison différente d'une fin d'une autre
saison c'est donc là c'est une saison
classique il y à un certain nombre de
rendez-vous qu'il faut pas manquer
notamment pour être dans le bateau qui
va
les défend les couleurs de la france aux
jeux olympiques parce que le bateau est
qualifié mais les romains sont pas
encore sélectionné les rameurs ils
seront sélectionnés au cours de la
saison en fonction des performances
qu'on va faire tout au long de la saison
et notamment sur le championnat de
france bateaux courts qui a lieu début
avril lors des championnats de france
indoor aussi alors laissez-vous semaine
c'est l'une justement des étapes du
chemin si la sélection c'est l'une des
performances qui est regardé on a déjà
fait un autre exercice de ce type là au
mois de décembre
donc là ce qu'on regarde c'est vraiment
un chrono une valeur physique mais où on
s'abstrait de toutes les contraintes
techniques
donc c'est sais pas c'est important mais
ce n'est pas à l'état primordial denis
landart on prépare quand on le prépare
comme ans ce rendez vous c'est forcément
pas un rendez vous classique comme les
autres là on prépare à fêter vos parents
et vos classiques non simplement ça
c'est une construction sur le très long
terme
c'est pas une construction je dirais
c'est une construction qui a commencé il
ya quand il avait 12 ans donc c'est bien
avant de réfléchir à l'objectif de
maintenant et comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est un sport où il ya beaucoup
de travail donc c'est d'abord de
l'abnégation jour le jour 1 c'est à dire
que les les centièmes comme dans tous
les sports qui ont une valeur jédir
chronométrique ou une confrontation
directe des centièmes il gagne à
l'entraînement il gagne ou un chacun à
l'entraînement ensuite dans cette année
olympique il ya un élément qui tout cas
je le souhaite peut être vraiment
important c'est évidemment la sélection
de la coque
ça existe d autres années mais quand on
n'est pas dans la coque olympiques comme
c'était le cas pour thomas ans en 2014
il ya des bateaux non olympique dans
lequel on peut aller faire des courses
et on peut quand même s'exprimer là
cette année s'il n'est pas dans le iv
évidemment il est pas au jeu et ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce qui se passe
quand même avec thomas c'est que depuis
2009 il progresse tout le temps il en
progression constante sur toutes les
valeurs et évidemment il s'est installé
petit à petit comme
vraiment un homme fort du bateau il
avait donc en 2014 il n'était pas dans
le bateau il a reconquis sa place avec
brio l'an dernier il a montré en allant
chercher une médaille de bronze qui
était la première médaille en quatre
depuis 2008 pour l'équipe de france il a
montré qu' il avait vraiment apporter
quelque chose cet équipage donc alors
évidemment il faut qu'il soit
sélectionné sélection officielle c'est
le 26 juin
donc là les noms des gens qui adorent le
temps oui c'est donc avec la télé bien
sûr également
et voilà il faut éviter bien sûr c'est
un risque donc il ya cette épée de
damoclès quand même qui est importante
mais on est finalement en 2012 c'est une
bonne surprise là il faut d'abord
préserver ses capacités son intégrité
pour pouvoir assurer sa qualification
très honnêtement il ay là il est très
très armé pour ça cette année et il ya
beaucoup de confiance en son sa
potentialité de le faire donc là on est
dans l'année de la confirmation pourtant
on est de l'année de la confirmation
clairement aux pluies et puis c'est une
année où derrière qui il ya aussi une
considération très différente c'est
qu'ils aient une médaille en france
cette année au championnat du monde à
quatre sans barreur et donc la question
c'est pas simplement d'aller où je suis
allée aux jeux c'est bien mais c'est
aller au jeu pour aller chercher une
médaille et c'est évidemment ça
l'objectif de l'année c'est pas aller
aux jeux aller aux jeux c'est bien mais
si on cherche simplement aller au jeu et
qu'on cherche pas aller houleuse pour
chercher la médaille est bon on fait pas
assez on s'entraîne pas si on n'est pas
assez motivés on est simplement là pour
essayer d'avoir une qualification en
uniforme se passe à l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de chercher les
médailles il vous met la pression en
disant ça il met la pression et non il
résuma effectivement ce qui se passe
tous les jours à l'entraînement parce
que clairement sur une saison comme ça
on n'y pense plus que d'habitude
dire que quand ça fait mal
et qu'on se demande pourquoi on est en
train de se faire aussi mal tous les
jours qu'on n'a pas envie
la motivation
revient assez vite quand on pense que on
a une chance d'aller chercher une
médaille olympique
à la fin de l'année et physiquement sa
part comment vous sentez vous
physiquement on se prépare huron central
une vingtaine d'heures par semaine
effective donc vraiment sur le bateau
sous les barres de monsieur ou en train
de courir de faire du vélo
on a un entraînement qu est assez
diversifié avec une partie importante en
musculation et beaucoup de kilomètres en
bateau parce que on a besoin d'une
finesse technique qui ne s'acquiert que
km à 20 km et ses bateaux vous allez
partager avec thibaut collard voilà
c'est important d'avoir une bonne
cohésion avec son ancien coéquipier dans
alors c'est important
c'est très important de d'avoir vraiment
confiance mais profondément confiance et
de doutes et à aucun moment de des
personnes avec lesquelles on en ramenant
le bateau parce que voilà si on a un qui
lâche que le conçoit 2 ou 4
la course est finie donc
donc on peut pas se permettre de douter
avec thibault ça se passe vraiment très
bien
et puis même au delà de ça dans le
bateau à 4 de l'année dernière ça se
passait déjà bien et on espère pouvoir
capitaliser justement sur l'expérience
de l'année dernière et en profiter cette
année
des sections sont pas fait encore une
fois mais voilà si c'est sûr que un
bateau médaillé sur une année pré
olympique
quand même quelques cartouches de
réserve et quelques évidemment sur le
dos de bateaux possible et vous misez
tout sur ces jeux olympiques en 2016 où
vous dites qu'il y aura peut-être
d'autres échéances qui vont venir
notamment à l'est les jeux olympiques
donc de 2020 actuellement je me projette
encore jusqu'en 2020 j'ai envie de
continuer je pense que je peux encore
progresser donné que je disais que je
t'ai toujours en progression
effectivement ça se voit que ce soit sur
le plan physique sur le plan technique
les chronos en bateau progresse d'année
en année donc c'est sûr que pour
l'instant la motivation et l'envié sont
toujours là donc je me projette jusqu'en
2001 maintenant voilà il sera temps de
faire le point après
les jeux olympiques en souhaitant que ça
se déroule de la meilleure des manières
possibles et puis on verra sur le projet
qu'on me propose l'envi qu'ils restent
mais à priori oui je continuerai
jusqu'en 2020 pour aller faire un tour
japon c'est un pays sympa denis je le
disais tout à l'heure
thomas a déjà participé à des jeux
olympiques est-ce qu'il faudra miser
enfin il faudra qu'ils emmagasinent
justement cette expérience qu'il a
acquis la u lors des derniers jeux
pourris pour gagner justement bien sûr
parce que c'est les jeux c'est quand
même un événement très particulier donc
il ya une pression et une pression
médiatique
on est là aujourd'hui par exemple c'est
vrai qu'on est un sport à ses
confidences donc parle pas souvent de
nous et puis et puis il ya évidemment
cette envie de réussir qui on a quand
même investi une énergie c'est 12
entraînements par semaine quand même
c'est une énergie importante pour
réussir ça donc il ya cette expérience
il ya aussi ce qu'il a dit est très
important je crois c'est avant la
cohésion de l'équipe
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui de savoir
travailler avec ses camarades d'avoir
construit le bateau un an à l'avancé
comme c'est un peu le cas j'espère moi
personnellement que le bateau qui a fait
championnat du monde qui a été médaillé
se poursuivra parce que ce qui a souvent
pêché les années précédentes c'est qu'on
a remodifier le bateau dernier moment et
donc on n'a pas installé la confiance
pour les rameurs et moi je crois que là
ils ont les armes pour pouvoir réussir
ça ils ont vécu une pression importante
puisque des championnats du monde en
france évidemment il y avait beaucoup de
monde y avait beaucoup de pression
beaucoup dans vie ils ont réussi à
sublimer ce moment là et ça c'est
vraiment du capital confiance
emmagasinée pour l'avenir la location
thomas barrau que nous sommes encore au
mois de janvier
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez qu'on vous
souhaite ça pourra pour cette année
qu'elle se déroule sans accroc
parce que
voilà une bonne saison c'est une saison
sans blessure c'est une saison on peut
s'entraîner d'un bout à l'autre sans que
rien ne vienne perturber pour l'instant
ça se passe bien voilà il ya toujours
une petite part de chance et d'imprévu
dans la vie donc dans le sport de haut
niveau et quand voilà quand tout est
bien en ligne c'est un plus merci à vous
donner de passer sur ce plateau c'était
un plaisir de vous recevoir bon courage
pour la suite de la saison mais pour
josé implique je pense que d'ici là on
prendra un petit peu la température
geste et à quelques semaines des jeux
olympiques
on ouvre après jean une page football
américain c'est officiel après un an
d'interruption la section des moins deux
saisons des templiers d'elancourt à
l'équipe de football américain de 50 ans
olivier a été relancé les apprentis
templiers ont joué ce week-end leur
premier match de la saison contre les
couacs williams elle pour les images la
section des u16 des templiers
d'elancourt renaît de ses cendres après
un an d'interruption ultime a été montée
cette saison pour disputer les phases
finales de la division territoriale
l'équivalent d'un championnat régional
on a décidé de relancer cette section
parce que vous voulez
assurer la pérennité du club donc la
pérennité du club c'est d'abord les
jeunes pour ensuite fournir aux équipes
seniors et crée la formation pour
l'équipe élite i c'est comme pour les
enfants qui vont à l'école on lui met à
l'école tout doux il tout petits pour
apprendre plus vite on pourra prendre
plus de choses au total qui inventent
joueurs se sont inscrits cette année
dans la structure saint-quentinoise le
principe est le fait que servir de de
statut ni conte de mettre en france de
rugby ces spots compétition dans
l'équipe alors que football me casser
l'esprit d'équipé super arrageoise pour
son retour la section u16 a remporté une
victoire 28 à 8 contre les couacs ce
d'or c'est ce samedi 23 janvier un
résultat important mais l'objectif est
avant tout de former ces jeunes
footballeurs
bien sûr tous déjà un rêve de finale
nous ce qu'on veut c'est qu'elle existe
et qu'elle ait une reconnaissance
ensuite qu'elle passe pourquoi pas
arriver aux play-offs parmi les
meilleures de sa de sa de son
département de sa région puis après on
verra
on prendra chaque match on prendra
chaque semaine et puis ça sera la cerise
sur le gâteau et puis si on a on va au
culot et bien pourquoi pas hein ça sera
très très bien mais on construit on est
là pour construire on n'est pas là pour
avoir des titres tout de suite on verra
dans les quelques années
prochain match pour les apprentis
templiers le samedi 13 février sur le
terrain des dragons de paris bisous sur
le club de montigny-le-bretonneux
on continue donc ce magazine par du
rugby l'équipe senior masculine de
montier bretons ne pointent actuellement
à la troisième place de 1re série pour
nous parler du club nous recevons sur ce
plateau l'entraîneur de l'équipe cyril
mûriers gwendal flory le capitaine et
jacques moreau le président bonsoir à
tous les trois alors je le disais
précédemment vous est troisième du
classement à la 11e journée c'est un tas
classement prévisible vous vous
attendiez à ce classement à ce milieu de
ses enfants vie je sais pas en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que tout le monde
tout mot et steve on est capable de
jouer les autres tableaux de façon
systématique envers série vu les progrès
de l'équipe
maintenant l'objectif reste de la
première place donc cette année ou
peut-être l'année prochaine on verra
bien vous avez manqué ce début de saison
contre senlis par exemple vous avez
perdu à 100 sur le terrain de senlis
lors de la 2e journée
c'est ça c'est récurrent du coup pour
mon team moto ne enfin la dernière vous
aviez connu le même début de saison
difficile
finalement cette année c'est la même
chose c'est ce finalement ces résultats
qui sont mauvais début de saison qui
boit qui vont plomber la le reste de
l'année
alors ça avait été clairement le cas
l'année dernière où un seul résultat
avait suffi pour nous femmes a raté la
première place on a effectivement raté
senlis cette année à peu près le même
genre de match
au delà de ça il ya deux équipes assez
fort dans la poule on a quand même perdu
dont on n'a pas vu contre colomiers et
contre neuilly
ce sont les deux équipes avec qui on va
jouer la montée mais c'est vrai qu'on la
dit peut être pas petite différence
c'est qu'on n'est pas régulier et on a
un match tous les arts on a un match
qu'on perd qu'on devrait pas wayne dalle
comment expliquez-vous du coup ce début
de saison au niveau des eaux au niveau
des joueurs je sais pas ça peut être lié
à un manque d'envié manque de
préparation je sais pas forcément
recrutement ou si on n'a pas de
recrutement on est vraiment tout petit
club on essaie de construire plutôt donc
sur les effets des joueurs conforme mais
non non c'est plutôt un manque d envie
ce fut un manque de préparation par
rapport à ce premier match qui ne vous
comprends pas et chaque année donc le
groupe n'est pas forcément différent
serré mûriers des années précédentes
vous avez fait quelques mots tiède
quelques changements peut-être les est
il des changements notre hymne à la
curée sur par rapport aux ans garçons
qui vont soit travail et étrangers soit
vont province pour leurs études ou là
quelques jeunes qui montent donc on a
vraiment petit vivier petit à petit qui
va venir nous consolider
oui c'est que les joueurs ont fait pas
mal de progrès mais pour pour passer au
palier suivant il faudrait qu'ils une
dimension physique plus sérieuse qui se
prennent davantage en main et qu'ils
soient plus acteur sur leur préparation
physique qui nous permettraient de
progresser techniquement et de faire
beaucoup de fautes
donc vous êtes actuellement à donc à la
troisième place à 13 points de la
première place avec un match en moins
c'est fini pour la montée cette année
non c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
puisque on reçoit les deux les deux
équipes de colomiers et de neuilly
seulement ça dépendra pas que de nous
c'est que même si nous gagnons ces deux
matches il faudra aussi que les deux
équipes trébuche ailleurs donc c'est pas
fini c'est pas bien parti mais c'est pas
fini
vous y croyez encore pour gwendal pour
la montée je crois un peu moins mais
j'aimerais bien attention on va vous
sortir l'équipe j'espère pas mais
j'aimerais bien pouvoir jouer les phases
finales en ile de france cette année
donc finir dans les deux premiers de la
poule c'est quand même notre objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés
voilà qu'on s'est fixés avec les joueurs
en cette fin d'année
et comment gère-t-on du coup cette
deuxième partie de saison sachant qu'il
ya un écart quand même assez conséquent
avec le premier on gère comment du coup
au niveau de l'effectif
on essaie chaque match les remobiliser
ou quel est votre rôle si un ouvrier
bain des cdg 2 le maximum de joueurs
qu'ils puissent parler le même langage
saultain donc on essaie de faire un
petit peu de turn over mesure de
possibilités mais
nous redoutons que quelques entraîneurs
on se fixe pas absolument la montée ou
autres on essaie que les joueurs le
meilleur rugby possible ils sont plus
performants le plus précis qu'un maximum
de maîtrise et les russes et avons des
coûts est tout seul mais ça travaille un
petit peu de fond qu'on essaie de mener
et comment gère-t-on cette deuxième
partie de saison on prépare déjà
peut-être là la saison prochaine en
sachant qu'on a un retard de points où
justement on va dire que tous les matchs
tous les matchs doivent être âpre et
disputé non en fait on est encore dans
la saison on a perdu on a perdu d'un
point à 2 minutes de la fin
neuilly-sur-marne donc on est tout près
de ses équipes
on est presque à leur niveau donc il ya
quand même une chance il ya comme le
disait gwendal ya un championnat de
france et un championnat de france où
les trois premiers sont qualifiés donc
c'est ça reste du challenge intéressant
après l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine se fera on a une grosse équipe
junior cette année donc dont pas mal
d'éléments intéressants monte l'année
prochaine donc c'est vrai qu'on peut
être très confiant sur le moyen terme
puisque comme l'elysée - dalle noueront
ne reprendre que de poires en forme et
et on a des équipes de jeunes à bon
niveau depuis des années donc moi je
suis convaincu que sur le sur le long
terme
forcément ça va se faire c'est
obligatoire inventée pour un club comme
anti sait jamais vous et du bonus s'est
jamais obligatoire c'est ici tellement
aléatoire une équipe simplement qui
monte sur dix c'est compliqué mais c'est
vrai que ça serait une juste récompense
une juste récompense d'un groupe qui est
quand même de bon niveau qui ruent tous
ces jeunes ont eu des très bons
résultats chez les cadets chez les
juniors donc c'est pas obligatoire mais
ça serait un plus
très intéressant par rapport au ton
projet que qui est bien en place aussi
on peut voilà ça serait intéressant par
rapport à ce projet là de projet de jeu
qui mis en place un c'est un projet de
jeu qui est pour eux une année c'est ce
sont des bons termes
on sent que cette implication là pour
nous c'est important de savoir qu'on va
retrouver ses bases et l'année prochaine
on travaille pas dans le film pour nous
c'est important et qu'on sait quels
projets ont construit voilà les joueurs
le savent
nous on voudrait monter on veut accéder
la plus grande division
pour nous c'est important dernière
question c'est un mur il y a un match
contre pantin ce week-end victoire
impérative bas pourtant je crois qu'ils
ont qu'une victoire c'était donc
j'espère que oui que le match va
rapidement le plier pour travailler sur
des détails qui nous font défaut encore
pour préparer les échanges un peu plus
difficile puis après on enchaîne me dont
7 1 et colomiers donc on monte crescendo
sur quatre matches on va essayer d'être
efficace merci à tous les toits n'êtes
pas assez sur ce plateau un bon courage
pas assidus champlain passe maintenant
aux autres résultats du week-end on
commence cette rubrique résultats par la
coupe de france fin de l' aventure du fc
mantois 78 dans la compétition les sang
et or yvelinois qui évolue en cfa se
sont inclinés mercredi dernier en 16e de
finale au stade aimé abergel après
prolongation 1 0 contre le club de ligue
1 du fc nantes
le but a été marqué par l'américain
alejandro bedoya en écoute les réactions
des acteurs à la fin de la rencontre
on attendait vraiment les tirs au but on
avait réussi à les amener en
prolongation le but il est l objet qui
fait l'état attend après ça j'ai joué 70
minutes donc voilà une erreur
d'inattention contredit
les ligue 1 ça paie cash et ce soir on a
été plutôt pas mal défensivement après
comme je disais je regrette qu'il ait
manqué un peu de folie
ça va un super état d'esprit ils ont un
rayon donné leur maximum puis voilà on a
un certain moment juste à la fin on a
été honorable qui peut changer ce que je
pense qu'ils vont nous égaliser mais bon
sur le sur la vue du match c'était
mérité mais absolument pas surpris par
par le contraire pour ce match
historique du fc mantois 78 près de 5000
spectateurs ont assisté à la rencontre
on passe au rugby en fédérale 3 plaisir
continue sur sa lancée les hommes
coachés par jean louis se sont imposés
dans la douleur sur le terrain d'evreux
ce dimanche le score 10 à 9 pour les
yvelinois au classement cette courte
victoire a permis à ris orangis de
reprendre la tête du championnat à la
différence de points devant plaisir le
prochain match contre caen programmé ce
dimanche sera très important dans la
course à la montée
toujours en fédérale 3 mais cette fois
ci dans la poule 2 les versailles et se
devait de réagir pour garder une infime
chance dans la course pour le maintien
et les hommes de la cité royale n'ont pu
faire mieux qu'un match nul contre
boulogne billancourt le score 11 partout
au classement aller vers ces îles sont
toujours derniers du championnat avec
quatre points de retard sur le premier
non relégable
elle survit dans cette fédérale 3
s'annonce donc compliquée c'est la fin
de ces puits de sport merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
un nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78